Taking a trip on an airplane anytime soon?
A new computer simulation shows just how far sneeze particles...
...travel in a crowded airplane cabin.
Engineers simulated the airflow to show how a sneeze spreads in the enclosed space...
...to help public health officials better understand...
...and potentially combat airborne infectious diseases.
The engineers identified the zone most likely to be infected by a nearby sneezer.
The good news?
Researchers say the risk of catching something isn't as high as you think.
While it's certainly possible to get sick from another passenger,...
...it doesn't happen nearly as often as it could, given the high volume of air traffic.